this area bets from the University in
Jerusalem so thanks for inviting me and
thanks for organizing this has been a
pleasure so far this is joint work with
Nia Dreyfus and matte Arabian benaiah is
a grad student at Hebrew you in the idea
for the paper came from him and much of
the work I am going to argue that
expectations based loss aversion may
help explain seemingly dominated choices
in strategy proof mechanisms this paper
is the winner of the longest titled and
best hyphenated paper in the conference
so the idea is simple deferred
acceptance I don't have to tell you what
it is in this crowd we heard a lot about
it in the past today's is widely
implemented one of the attractive
features is that under the assumption of
classical preferences it's a strategy
proof so it induces preference
concordant or aka truthful ranking it's
a dominant strategy so I don't care what
others do it in my interest again under
classical preferences I'm gonna keep
emphasizing this it's a dominant
strategy to just rank options let's say
schools by the order of preferences I'm
going to use the term truthful during
the talk and I'm going to use mr.
presentation the term misrepresentation
of preferences when people are going to
submit a list that doesn't coincide with
classical preferences
I want to say early on this is a
misnomer from the point of view of my
argument today
and I'm just gonna use it to not
introduce new terms I imply no normative
judgment by it
there's nothing about when people
participate in these mechanisms there's
nothing about please tell us the truth
or please don't lie to us there's none
of that so we don't like the terms but
I'm going to keep using them today there
is a recently evidence that is
uncomfortable so you know we're very
happy that we have this strategy proof
mechanisms it's a great achievement of
some of us and you know we gave Nobel
prizes for it etc but it's we're a
little uncomfortable when we see
recently evidence that people still try
to strategize or do not reveal their
true preferences in these mechanisms the
evidence is quite overwhelming so in the
lab people have to rank essentially
amounts of money and they don't rank
them by the order of you know monetary
value sometimes in simple environments
where misunderstanding doesn't quite
seem like the most intuitive explanation
in the field we're talking about high
stakes environments people often leave a
lot of money on the table not always
sometimes they make costless mistakes
but there is this evidence so the
projects that I'll talk about today
could be described from two points of
view one point of view is we have this
puzzling evidence that people play
seemingly dominated playing the strategy
proof mechanisms how can we explain it
and the answer would be we have a set of
models
reference on the reference dependent
references are specifically expectations
based loss aversion that are going to
explain some such behavior so I'm not
going to claim that all the mistakes I
can now explain with its model but the
the model is going to be is going to do
much better than a classical preference
the other way to explain to describe
this project is to go the other way
around to say you know we have this
field of the overal economics we have
some workhorses in that field one of
them is these sets of models of
expectations based reference dependence
in we've also been giving Nobles for
that and we see in the law in recent
years these models are applied in more
and more contexts so we see behavior
patent finance and behavioral IO and
behavioral this and behavioral debt and
so let's take them now and bring them to
deferred acceptance or to other matching
mechanisms and just analyze the
consequences what do we get under these
models so this project in a way does
both things when you ask yourself what
will happen to loss averse individuals
when they play in deferred acceptance
mechanisms you get some predictions and
then low and behold it seems to be
exactly the predictions that I just
called 20 seconds ago puzzling evidence
of how people behave so that's basically
the story of this model this paper I'm
going to have three parts of the talk
the first part I'll introduce the
mechanism I don't really need to
introduce it here but I'll show a little
bit and show really just a few minutes
of the evidence that people do play
against seemingly dominated choices then
I'll talk a little bit about the theory
I'll introduce the ebert model the
expectations based reference dependent
preferences model and discuss some
predictions and then in the third part I
am going to analyze lab evidence from
serial dictatorship market which is a
restriction of deferred acceptance and
I'm going to show that the behavior in
that lab experiment actually matches the
model quite nicely fortunately we didn't
have to run the experiment because
xiangu already ran experiments better
than we could have run them so we just
downloaded this data and reanalyze it so
that's also another advantage of posting
or data when we publish a papers there
is certainly positive externalities here
what I'll show in the third part is that
the Ebert model does much better than
the classical model the Ebert model
actually nests the classical model so
the classical model a version of the
classical model is a special case of the
Ebert model so I'm going to be able to
run likelihood ratio tests and to show
you that the model does much better than
the standard or I shouldn't call it
standard model the classical model
because sooner or later the model I'm
talking about today will become standard
and now this is on video and we won't
know when I said it so I shouldn't say
standard yeah okay oh this is actually
important so it's not that I find some
anomalies or confusing behavior and then
I'm saying okay I'm gonna invent a new
model that explains it
no I'm taking off the Shelf a standard
model standard for us in behavioral
economics with the same I'm going to
calibrate the parameter so I'm going to
estimate some parameters specifically
the parameter of loss aversion and the
famous lambda
I'll show that the degree and
distribution of lambda that we find in
other contexts or that explains risk
aversion in other contexts is the same
one that will explain the data here
better than the model some in a way
limited by a limiting a my degrees of
freedom although I am anything a degree
of freedom a relative to classical
preferences okay so that's a story of
the talk I'll try to go quickly this one
is not connected so it's symbolic value
so this is a web page from the match the
National residency and rmp match program
for for you know medical students in
this country match to residences
there's a lot of explanation on how the
mechanism works there is a video that I
won't have time to show but basically
they explain deferred acceptance to
people here is one screen from the video
that you can watch or from another video
that you can watch on the website they
really emphasize how to how you should
play ranked your most preferred program
first then second and third do not rank
programs based on where you think you
might match the probabilities you have
in your mind of each school are
irrelevant you should ignore them there
is no penalty for ranking a rich program
if it's your most preferred program so
rich program something you think you
never get you won't get punished for not
putting it first for putting it first
etc sometimes some of these images have
cut-offs so you have some standardized
test score and different schools or
different problems would have different
cut-offs and then they the instructions
typically say something like you know
get the highest ranked alternative so
that your score exceeds its cutoff it's
usually Oh
so let me say a few words about evidence
so in the lab people play deferred
acceptance or variations of differed
acceptance and they basically try to
submit less where they rank hypothetical
schools the schools are symbolized
different amount of money there is
something like 15 studies that we survey
in the paper they all find that people
misrepresent now in the lab assuming you
like money we know your true preferences
over the sums of money and different
studies find between 19 and 45 percent
of the submitted list do not rank the
amounts of money by by value I think
particularly interesting is is the paper
by Alex with Jones in score on neck
where they take the same medical
students who have just participated in
the Ayrton RMP and they play a lab game
with them with the same match the same
rules etc and even they find high levels
of misrepresentation among these
students so that's worrying in the field
it's usually much more difficult to
identify misrepresentations because we
don't know the ranking we don't know
your preferences however in some
contexts we can identify preference
misrepresentation specifically there is
a bunch of recent papers where the
researchers identify markets where you
are offered a certain program at a
certain school in two versions one with
fellowship or with funding and one
without and they are otherwise identical
and so here again assuming that you like
money we
would want to see a ranked the funded
position above the non funded one
however these studies find between 19
and 35 percent of the relevant rank
ordered lists or rank ordered lists that
have in them the pair of programs
otherwise identical but one of them is
funded and they find what they call
obvious misrepresentations sometimes not
always sometimes these are costly so one
example from one study in Hungary the
average costly misrepresentation cost a
few thousand dollars the the average
misrepresentation cost a few hundred
dollars so we're talking about real
money here of course these are lower
bound so these are just the the obvious
misrepresentations who knows how many
misrepresentations that are not obvious
are out there so that's the evidence
here's an example from a market in
Israel for psychology students and I
have a translation for those who don't
speak Hebrew
but the person ranked did an obvious
misrepresentation right they rank the
program above a funded program and they
get this screen this pop-up that says
attention you ranked clinical psychology
without scholarship at the Hebrew
University but you did not rank clinical
psychology with scholarship at the
Hebrew University do you want to keep
the current ranking anyway and people
click OK a lot of them in fact everyone
who did this got the screen and kept
okay
so it could be I actually spent a lot of
time talking to the people who design
the the the mechanisms you know they try
to do everything they can to explain to
people that this is not the case I
cannot rule it out I'll show you later
evidence where I think it's this cannot
be the explanation why the option yes so
great question let's say you wanna go
this is your preference you want to go
to Hebrew University with funding if you
can't get that you want to go to Tel
Aviv University with funding if you
can't get that you want to go to Hebrew
University without funding so they need
to actually give you okay
all right let me tell you something
about this misrepresentation so we see
trends in the data it's very common in
the lab studies to see that basically
applicants are misrepresentations or
sums of money where they have a lower
chance to get them lower than should be
implied by the value and in the field we
also see that when the likelihood of
admission or the likelihood of funding
is lower people seem to misrepresent
more now here you could say in the field
well what sort of people have a lower
probability to get the funding probably
weaker students maybe weaker students
just make more mistakes so there is some
neat evidence that shows that it could
be even causal so it's not just that
here's an example from Hungary where the
government at some point made getting
funding much harder for some programs
but not for others and you can see these
are the programs where in 2012 I think
or in 2013 it became much harder to get
funding for them in the amount of
obvious mr. presentations jumped
dramatically for these programs but not
for the others so we have some evidence
this is cause of that reducing the
likelihood of getting the amount of
money actually makes people drop down
the list or even drop out of the list
the options with the money
so in general subjects seem to try to
increase the chances of getting their
highest two ranked choices and not
necessarily the the most money or the
most preferred school and as I said
before we get exactly these predictions
from the expectations based referent
dependent preferences model the
intuition is pretty simple to explain in
these models you don't care only about
final outcomes but you also care about
final outcomes relative to what you
expected in you suff
a lot for disappointment you suffer a
lot for getting less than what you are
expected you get some price for getting
more than what you expected but the pain
of getting less is much more painful
than the fun of getting more that's what
we call loss of version and we have a
Greek letter lambda that describes this
loss aversion so lambda is above 1 I'll
show you later the model itself but if
you don't like getting disappointed and
there is a school or something you
really want that you will get with low
probability it's sometimes better for
you not to set yourself up for a
disappointment and just to give it up
from the get-go okay what I'll show in
the estimation a part which is the last
part of the talk I'll show that if we
take this the classical model classical
preferences plus mistakes a the
likelihood of which goes up when the
cost of the mistake goes down
so think about logic a quantile response
equilibrium model you know you play
dominant strategy but you make mistakes
and you make more mistakes when they are
less costly that's going to be my
benchmark and against that I'm gonna a
testing Ebert version where you maximize
utility but make mistakes more so when
they're less likely and as I said before
this model is going to fit the data much
better than that this one the likelihood
ratio test suggests that they the
likelihood that the data came from this
model is 10 to the 7 times more likely
then then it came from that model yes it
seems important that I won't learn Expo
what I would have gotten had I chosen
differently
no if so I set it to zero to make sure I
prefer having a zero chant made ruling
alcohol
I didn't think about that I think it
would work either way so you so actually
in the model it's fine you know the
problem you know the probability you
know the true probability you maximize
expected utility and yeah of course
sometimes you know once you know the
realization you would have acted
differently but based on the information
you have at the moment of making the
choice the choice is pretty clear okay
so very quickly theory people react to
departures in their consumption from the
reference point the reference point can
be stochastic or deterministic the
standard model is consumption utility so
we get utility from consuming things in
this model there is another term noise
utility news utilities as I said before
is new beliefs about consumption
relative to let beliefs about
consumption or in the version that I'll
talk about today you're gonna consume
something that's gonna be the school or
the amounts of money so you're going to
enjoy consuming them as in the standard
model but also you're gonna compare
consuming them to what you expected to
consume and if you're above it it's
great and if you below it it's really
bad how bad depending on how loss averse
you are so the reference point is your
rational expectations the rational
expectations once you submit a list the
list is a lottery the list is basically
probabilities over getting different
prizes and that becomes your reference
point okay so let me skip this but just
give you a simple example so three
periods in Laura's life Laurie submits a
rank ordered list in a deferred
acceptance like mechanism in there is
only one school right so
she learns that with probability P I she
will attend si from which she gets
utility mi okay so what kinds of utility
does she experience at the end of the
day this is going to be the sum of
everything I'm gonna break it down so
first of all at the moment when she
submits the list she gets news relative
to let's assume she started with zero
zero beliefs so what's the nose the nose
is that with probability P I you'll
consume mi that's the lottery okay now
she waits and then she learns the result
of the match did she get the school or
not so now she gets news utility from
there realization with probability P I
she gets the school so she gets she
enjoys mi but this is the good news
component so with probability P I
relative to believing that she would not
have gotten the school this was the
belief when she submitted it she knew
with 1 minus P she won't get it so
relative to that she now gets the school
and experience good news however with
probability 1 minus P I she want to get
the school and relative to believing she
would get it she suffers how much does
she suffer that's the coefficient of
loss aversion lambda that is above 1 I'm
going to estimate lambda later and then
comes the rest of her life she consumes
the school with probability P is the
same probability so over all over the
three periods of her life she has these
two actually four terms and we can sum
them together and so we get twice
expected value one time from consuming
it one time from the news at the moment
of submitting the list that you will
consume it of course in probability and
we have this news component that is on
average negative because lambda is above
one so this is positive and this is
negative and it goes up with a spread
with the mean absolute difference
measure of the lottery okay let's think
of a to school example very quickly
so I have two schools let's assume that
I like s1 better than s2 but let's
assume that the probability to get into
s1 is lower than s2 if I rank s1 about
this - I get this lottery actually this
whole lottery and I built it exactly the
way I did before you know there's a
probability q1 I'll get m1 and then
there is the nose and then there is also
a probability that I'll get rejected
from Q 1 in which case there is a
probability of Q it from s1 probability
Q 2 that I'll get the second school etc
if I misrepresent I flip them it's the
same formula just flip all the
subscripts
so then you get a condition when will I
wanna misrepresent under this condition
and for example if my lambda is 3 so I'm
a loss averse this is my loss aversion
and the probability to get into the
least preferred school is 1 but into the
more preferred school is 1/2
I will actually misrepresent as long as
I prefer the better school by no more
than a factor of 3 so I will skip that
but this shows some examples of when
we'll get mr. presentation the colors
are terrible and in some cases you
actually will just drop one of the
schools so you actually prefer not to
even list it this violates a first-order
stochastic dominance we can generalize
the results from more than two schools
let me just say if you have a list of
schools order them by the most prefer to
the list by fair unless the
probabilities are the uncle the
conditional probabilities to get into
them into each of the schools unless the
probabilities also go from lowest to
highest with the same order preferences
there are some conditions under which
you would misrepresent okay yes yes so
yes I think we think we can generalize
it easily to correlate the queue so of
course if you got rejected from the
first score maybe you'll learn that your
letters are really bad so now so I think
this is not an issue but we didn't prove
it yet I ever result for the money I
will skip it I'll skip it okay let me
talk about the empirics yes that you
can't rush
so
in the in the school case so I'm
assuming that utilities linear in money
and then I know I have this ratio so I
have conditions on the like this
condition on the ratio so if you if m1
was ten times m2 yeah in case of money
in the estimation now I have small
amounts of money and I'm assuming linear
utility in money and so I can calculate
all of this and then I can estimate your
lambda based on the choices I see you
making yeah yeah so sure this is exactly
what I'm going to show in the last 17
minutes that I have so I'm going to use
a sheng gu's a experiment these are the
instructions and I'll just summarize
them very quickly okay so the game is as
follows there are four people in your
group in for prizes on the table the
four prizes are drawn randomly without
replacement from slightly more than four
prizes you then draw a priority score
from the earn it's an integer between
one and ten that will determine the
order with which you will choose which
of the prizes you want and there is a
tie breaking rule it's just a 50-50
thing and then this is from the
instructions the player with the highest
priority score will be assigned the top
prize on the lathe the player with the
second highest priority score will be
assigned the top prize on his list among
the prizes that remain etcetera
instructions are very easy to understand
by some measure that Shang Wu can
explain to us about later subjects
played and they then they learn they get
feedback on what was the realized
priority were they first or second or
third or fourth to choose and
which prize they won we have 72 subjects
that play 10 rounds of these games of
720 observations this is the choice
screen where they have the four prizes
and they have to click here one two
three four and submitted they have 90
seconds to submit it and then they learn
sorry that so they know the priority
score and they have to rank and submit
okay so we can analyze the situation
from an Ebert point of view and this is
going to be your utility basically you
have the four prizes so this is the
expected value plus the news utility
from submitting and this is the gain
loss component you know the problem so
you know know is a big word to say but
these are the probabilities that you'll
be 1st 2nd 3rd or 4th as a function of
the priority score you drew from the
earn we're not assuming that people
actually have this table in their head
actually the table is not easy to
calculate because of ties so we
calculated it with simulation but all we
need is for is for people to understand
that if they got a 10 probably they will
be the first to choose and if not the
first they'll be the second they're not
going to be the fourth and if they got
the 1 probably they are the fourth
although there's some chance they'll be
the third ok
back
related
okay so alright so I'm gonna spend some
time on this figure so let me explain
them here we have the priority score
that you drew from the Arin one to ten
here we have the list that you could
submit one two three four is the
truthful list you put first the biggest
sum of money second the second-biggest
etc this one is you put the biggest
second biggest fourth biggest third
biggest now I'm gonna we're solving it
in the paper in two ways we need to know
so you know you're a priority score
based on it you have probabilities on
your order and you know the four sounds
but what you don't know is what others
are doing so here I'm gonna do the
simple thing you assume that others are
always playing one two three four it's
often right I think that 69% of the
lists that are submitted of the 720 are
one two three four of course it's not an
equilibrium belief because in
equilibrium some people misrepresent but
if these are your beliefs then if you
put one in after that three it's
actually doesn't matter the order of the
other two you will always going to
matter and if you put four first it
doesn't matter what you do next so there
are six of the 24 lotteries you could
submit right four factorial
these six give you actually the same
you'll always get the fourth prize no
matter what you did afterwards and no
matter what yeah okay so we only have so
we reduce the 24 possible lotteries to
submit to only eight and I'm showing you
now the utility expected utility we'll
get from each of the eight sets of
lottery submissions as a function of
each of the ten priority scores that you
could draw from the head and it's going
I'm going to show your colors that
represent utility they are normalized at
the column level so don't don't
/ across columns here's one example if
your lambda equals 1 which means this is
the standard model it boils down to
classical preferences it's always the
case no matter what your priority score
is it's always the case that your
utility is higher from just submitting 1
2 3 4 of course that's why the mechanism
is strategy proof you can see that some
mistakes are not costly for example if
you have a high priority score and you
submit instead of 1 2 3 4 1 2 4 3 you
basically don't lose much an expected
value why because you're almost for sure
going to be the first one and if not you
will be the second you're basically
never but will be 3 or 4 so that's a
cost that's a not costly mistake I'm
showing the data later nobody does it
here's a very costly mistake play 1 if
play 4 first
that's a very costly mistake why because
you're getting the lowest sum which most
of the time is $0 actually for sure no
matter what you do you know showing the
data that a lot of people actually
played so it's not that people make
mistakes that are less costly or
something like that okay so that's what
lambda 1 and I am going to use the balls
to show what in in each row for each
priority score that you could have drawn
from the head what's the best the
utility maximizing play so you can see
that for lambda 1 2 & 3 the best thing
to do is just to report 1 2 3 4 however
for higher lambdas 4 5 6
you actually maximize utility by
misrepresenting it's middle priority
scores you actually don't want if they
put 1 2 3 4 you're setting yourself up
for a disappointment and so you could
actually play some other things and it's
not just any other things it's specific
other things and I don't have time to
explain the intuition and with very low
priority score if you're sufficiently
loss averse you actually want to put the
4 first you use you hate uncertainty so
much and you're gonna do you get
disappointed mostly anyway that it's
just better to
me too getting zero or the lowest price
that maximizes your utility this is the
empirical these are the empirical
patterns that we actually see in the
data so these are what people choose as
I said I have 720 observations so these
are the priority scores that people
pulled out of the head and this is the
probability with which they played each
of the eight sets of lotteries you can
see that it priority 10 they almost
never misrepresent but that priority one
thirty nine percent of the time they
misrepresent and they Joe don't just
uniformly misrepresent they play exactly
21 percent they play four first 11
percent they play four three first you
see that at middle ranges they play
exactly these plays so let me show it
now in colors and compare it these are
the theoretical predictions a different
lambda different degrees of loss
aversion these are the empirical
patterns so as I said before 69 percent
of the rank order lists are one two
three four but we see a lot of
misrepresentation twenty nine percent
and we see them exactly where we are
supposed to see them you know in this
range we see them here in in this range
in the lower ranges we see them here and
here so this is all eyeballing let's do
a little bit of econometrics by the way
I won't have time for it now but in the
paper we also as I said analyze what are
the theoretical predictions not under
assuming that everybody else plays one
two three four but assuming that
everybody else plays exactly the
empirical distribution of plays that I
see in the data so then I cannot reduce
the 24 lotteries to eight sets now I
have to play all the lotteries because
no matter what you play there is never
certainty that you'll get it so I have
theoretical predictions and have
empirical patterns okay then what we do
is we do some econometrics so we
estimate a logit model I said before a
logit quantile a responsible every
basically just a logit model there
says your probability to play each of
the 24 lotteries is determined by the
logic function and I use it I use
maximum likelihood to estimate first of
all one lambda for the entire population
and then I get lambda equals two which
is a well within the range of lambdas
from the literature likelihood ratio
test I get the statistics of 30 the
statistic of 32 which as I said before
this suggests that the likelihood that
the data came from a lambda equals 2 is
10 to the 7 more likely than from the
lambda equals 1 model which is which is
the classical a preference model very
statistically significant I do some
robustness checks so for example I can
estimate only the first 5 rounds over
the last five rounds yesterday we saw
very quick convergence which we don't
get here we get this little convergence
but then it basically converges to
something like 25% misrepresentations in
the last rounds so it's not about learn
the mistakes early on that are corrected
later on
Shengo also ran a one-shot study later
on with 192 subjects in stakes that are
12 times higher so the bigger the
biggest sum now was $15 and so we also
estimate the model on that one we get
essentially the same coefficient of loss
aversion when we force the whole
population to have one lambda
that that's not a usual lambda no no oh
yeah yeah sorry I should have said it no
no no no no yeah that's the lambda from
my mod so when I said qre this is a
curie with the non standard utility
function
I actually don't estimate the parameter
what is it called here the rationality
parameter you know so I can't estimate
the cure in my I can't estimate the
rationality parameter in my model I can
estimate it for classical preferences I
don't know the answer to that so I do a
legit I do a legit mod is tomato logit
model we estimate a logic model where I
estimate lambda from the data and then I
do a likelihood ratio test against the
lambda equals 1 which is the standard
model I can also since every one of the
72 subjects play 10 rounds I can use
these 10 rounds to estimate the logit
model on the subject itself i only have
ten observations but you know I can
estimate personal lambda only for the 44
of the 72 subjects who didn't play one
two three four in all ten rounds those
who did the twenty eight subjects who
did play one two three four not twenty
eight Trump's their utility function
like Lee function is unbounded so I
can't estimate them so I only estimate
the so-called misrepresent errs and I
can show you the histogram and then I
can wait the histogram by standard
deviation because some of them give me
crazy numbers but also very crazy
standard error so you can see when I
divide by standard error the crazy ones
basically disappear and then I can also
do a kernel estimate of the way the
distribution and I can also estimate use
the mixed logic to estimate just a
normal distribution of the lambdas so
now I have only two free parameters for
the normal distribution the Mew and the
Sigma they basically all look the same
and then I can use that to report
statistics of the distribution under
assumptions about what is the lambda for
the 28 people that I can't estimate so
in the paper we do three assumption
there lambda is zero the lambda is 1
which is classical preferences and the
lambda is three which is the most loss
aversion you can have without exhibiting
first-order stochastic dominance so it's
the highest lambda that is consistent
with playing one two three four and we
find the range of estimates for the mean
lambda in the distribution that is again
between 165 to 3 very similar to what we
find in other contexts although these
comparisons are always to be taken with
a grain of salt so be careful let me
conclude I'll just say one thing
we have been pretty frustrated with
these people out there because we are
giving them a strategy proof mechanism
and they are doing weird stuff instead
of just revealing their preferences what
this evidence suggests is that we we may
have been a barking barking up the wrong
tree so it may be that the problem is
not that they misunderstand the
mechanism it's that we me specify the
preferences and they we tell them to
make the matching algorithm work best
for you create your rank ordered list in
order of your true preferences note how
you think you will mention people ignore
it not because they don't understand but
because given their preferences it's
actually very rare
want to take into account the
probability they don't like loss they
don't like to be disappointed so two
things I'll just say first of all even
if these are the Preferences then
they're trying to intentionally maximize
them we're not saying normatively these
are welfare relevant preferences we
actually think people are making a
mistake they put too much weight on the
news utility component of utility
function for all kinds of reasons that I
won't get into now but talk to me after
the talk so they may still be making
normatively mistake but these are
intentional mistakes these are not
calculation mistake or misunderstanding
mistakes these are they are maximizing
maybe a mistake in utility function due
to other behavioral biases and finally
of course we hope that to throw to the
mechanism design community this idea of
let's try to think hard about designing
mechanisms under these other preferences
the evidence is quite overwhelming that
the P again people are making mistakes
left and right but the evidence suggests
that they make them relative not to
classical preferences that's not what
they were trying to maximize they're
trying to maximize something else
maybe while we have nica's talk on this
laptop we can take a couple of questions
for Ori so so the game they are playing
with lots of us preferences looks like
immediate acceptance right yeah great so
that's a great yes so we have a long
discussion about it in the paper
what if they understand everything but
they have intuitions from life that are
very much Boston mechanism what is this
intuition this is tuition is don't go
for too far for too high because you may
end up with nothing and so there are
several features of the data that are
inconsistent with it I is very similar
to the AI a mechanism in that in the
sense that they have to right away
matched so no in the following sense
for example as I said before most of the
times in shengo's data the fourth price
is zero so you could not do worse than
putting it first under Boston or under
actually any monotonic mechanism that's
what people play these are most of the
misrepresentations so it doesn't seem to
be that
you have time yeah if it's a sorry keep
going yeah it's not easy sure we should
expect you in the state with their
choices are atomic right so what do this
data all these mistakes are they're all
one-shot salads or you actually see this
mistakes repeated so this came from ten
rounds in we in the robustness section
we actually look at the first five or
the last five and you could actually
also see how many mistakes they do as a
function of the round so you have ten
rounds so it goes down slightly it goes
down from something like it's 31 percent
of the rolls are mistaken in the first
five rounds and 27 percent in the last
five rounds but then it's pretty stable
it is basically pretty stable I mean it
jumps around but so yeah feedback every
round so it doesn't seem like a mistake
that they quickly correct
we should probably wrap just in this
time thank you
[Applause]